joe biden defending his disastrous
withdrawal from afghanistan while former
obama officials are calling him out and
biden is admitting well he could have
helped create a new terrorism safe haven
can al-qaeda come back yeah but guess
what it's already back other places
what's the strategy
every place where al qaeda is we're
going to invade and have troops stay
there
come on 70 american people think it was
time to get out of afghanistan spending
all that money but the flip of it is
they didn't like the way we got out
but it's hard to explain to anybody how
else could you get out
an image of sheer strength biden getting
slammed by former obama officials for
making the terror threat in america
worse
the taliban is harboring
zawahiri today
taliban is harboring al-qaeda today the
taliban winning the war in afghanistan
and then the way our exit
happened
has absolutely inspired jihadists all
over the world
not only will jihadists be inspired
but a lot of them are going to come to
afghanistan to be part of the
celebration to be hard to be part of
jihadist central
the most important thing for this
president to do is to be willing to
accept responsibility for the mistakes
and to move on
uh and to basically do what is necessary
now to protect our national security you
know dana you don't often see this
especially amongst democrats former
obama officials cia directors coming out
and saying accept responsibility because
you just made the problem and leon
panetta repeated the point that he
thinks that there was a mistake made or
mistakes made but you don't hear that
from anyone in the uh they've heard it
once no they're just they've linked arms
it's red rover red rover send them over
and like if you're sending over obama
people it reminded me of something
though pete do you remember during the
campaign when robert gates former
secretary of defense when his book came
out and he said joe biden has never been
right even once on any foreign policy
issue in the last 30 years
so that's very that's very
strong and as i recall there wasn't a
lot of defense of
the vice president at the time uh people
just didn't didn't pile on but they kept
their powder dry they didn't say much
and i think this is um part of that uh i
think americans want to be on offense
against al qaeda when president biden
says what were we going to do invade
every country that has al qaeda no one's
suggesting that these straw men our
arguments are really frustrating what
americans do expect is to be on offense
against al qaeda wherever they are and
that doesn't mean invasion and we can
argue about afghanistan and getting in
and then the mission and all that but
that again it's just a false equivalence
there the other thing i would say the
last thing is um
it took the botching of the afghanistan
hasty retreat to bring americans
together you now have bipartisan
agreement that
it was
that people wanted to get out of
afghanistan but that it was
handled terribly on the way out and
they're embarrassed by it they're
humiliated they want the americans to
get out the green card holders and those
vetted special immigrant visas to who
helped us for them to be able to get out
and it doesn't look like that's
happening anytime soon especially for
those sivs and the last bipartisan point
is that people do not feel more safe
today than they did before 9 11. well
that's true and jesse too to what dana
just said maybe the obama officials knew
who joe biden was all along and they
knew you put him in a situation like
this where you have to make dynamic
decisions he's going to dig his heels in
ultimately and place blame i don't know
anywhere else when i see people like
morel
and panetta
i see obama and i see hillary notice
hillary and barack have been dead silent
since this thing broke out and they're
kind of speaking for hillary and barack
and that's significant break down the
statement with me pete would you do me
the honor okay
can al queda come back yeah
but guess what it's already back in
other places does that make you feel
safe it makes me feel great how about
this what's the strategy every place
where al qaeda is we're gonna go invade
and have troops staying there come on
come on that's the biden doctrine straw
man followed by a come on
that's like dan is saying jesse
i don't like your hair dana you don't
like my hair well i'm just gonna shave
it off come on
let's do it let's do it no that makes no
sense and then he fills
how else could you get out joe turn on
the tube bro
every pundit on television been saying
you keep bogram you leave air support in
while you pull out the allies and the
civilians maybe coordinate with nato and
then get all the hardware out before the
chinese can steal it come on man
how could you get out maybe any other
way any other conceivable way
is this a democratic view jessica is it
is
what is the foreign policy of joe biden
what would democrats say their foreign
policy is right now if the
acknowledgement is well al qaeda might
just come back but al qaeda's all over
the place well i haven't heard anyone
but the president say that that's
certainly not what jen saki's saying
it's not what anthony blinken was saying
today that's something that the
president said in a very casual exchange
with a reporter i will give you that it
felt very casual on 9 11.
yeah i mean i don't i don't think that
anyone if you looked at joe biden's
schedule and the statement he put out on
9 11 i don't think that there's any way
to think that he doesn't care about it
or understand what happened on that day
so i really don't want to go there he
was at ground zero in the morning he
went to shanksville he released a great
statement so let's leave that but as for
the criticisms what's
more interesting to me about it is that
you say these are obama officials
they're obama biden officials it's an
administration right like they got
picked by barack and joe together to do
this job and obviously people have their
preferences and they say you know i want
this guy you want this guy or this gal
but those are people from your own team
making that criticism which is why i
think the binding administration has
been extra quiet about it because it's
not just democrats saying it it's ones
that you worked with for years right and
people who you often worked with for
decades if you're in this kind of
position certainly in terms of foreign
relations since he was the chairman
but that's what makes the criticism
katie that much more stinging is that if
they are trying to avoid it they can't
avoid reality which is ultimately
michael morale saying we've inspired
jihadists uh
could joe biden actually act to take on
al qaeda and this administration if if
necessary of course he could i mean
that's why we have the u.s military we
have the capability to do this they're
choosing not to joe biden and i would
say it doesn't matter if the secretary
the press secretary is saying something
or the secretary of state is saying
something that's different and that's
what we want to focus on the president
of the united states is in charge of the
security of the country it's the
commander-in-chief's number one job is
protecting americans especially from
foreign threats and this idea that he's
saying well al-qaeda's everywhere so
throwing up my hands and it's a very
defeatist attitude and he's has this
attitude from a position of weakness
where we are relying on the taliban to
get people out there are americans left
behind his attitude should be we will
fight them wherever they are we have the
capability to do that and they shouldn't
mess around
and find out but instead he's saying oh
well what do you want me to do
that's your job your job is to do
something instead we've been taking
effectively orders from the taliban and
you want to look at a future of our
ability to strike
we don't have human intelligence we have
signals intelligence which means you
don't have all the ingredients you would
normally have which means you end up
droning a aid worker with water bottles
we're getting intelligence
suicide bomber right